some of the best street food i've ever
eaten was in asia
every one of those little markets was
filled with smells of delicious food
that all centered around an asian staple
noodles learn to cook those properly and
you'll be surprised how quick and easy
it is to knock up a delicious dinner
first off we're going to soak our
noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water
over the rice noodles
soak and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got a wok perfect if not just a normal
size frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
to slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin and to cut it into strips
take your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half like a sort of
scallop
like that
we call this butterfly in the chicken
take a rolling pin
and nice and gently roll over the
chicken what it does it sort of flattens
it allows you to slice it
even thinner
and the thinner the slices of the
chicken
the sort of crisper it gets the quicker
it cooks slice it in half
start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily
next wash your knife and finely slice
garlic
the thinner the garlic
the crispier
[Music]
this is a
young
tender
broccoli just slice them down
i want a bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables
and one-third of your protein chicken
[Music]
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil
get a pan really nice and ready
just starting to smoke drop the chicken
in first
[Music]
salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
once you've started to sear off the
chicken
get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the
pan can see why it's so important to cut
the chicken thin strips because it
colors and cooks at the same time as
well really really crucial
now that garlic's getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
feels strange putting raw broccoli
in like that normally
we'll blanch it in boiling water dry it
out but
you want that crunch
now soy sauce that helps to season it
but also stains beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
it's exactly what i want now take that
out
give you a pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
wok
really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing
this quick stir fry very classic two
eggs
in
[Music]
whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it
at the side of the pan
lightly season
the eggs
noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
and give that
a really nice mix
you want the egg to sort of almost
bring the dish together
that egg's cooked
[Music]
make sure you've got that nice even
distribution of
chicken
broccoli
garlic
lovely
and then just finish that fresh lime
and then you have a very
simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
making your enoki is so simple to do yet
the results are absolutely stunning and
it's a great way of using up leftover
baked potatoes
you can make noki just with flour and
eggs however the potato gives it a nice
light sort of creamy fluffy texture cut
them in half take your spoon
and scoop
the inside of those potatoes
i'm using leftover baked potatoes but
this really works as well with leftover
ball potatoes two choices
you can get a fork and sort of mash the
potato and get it nice and light and
fluffy or
this little gadget is called a ricer i
suppose it's a posh word
for a potato masher just squeeze gently
you can see how nice and light it is
almost like fluffy little strands of
potato
you can do this when the potatoes are
hot it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
[Music]
now
a nice spoon of okata ring a little
touch of salt and pepper it's really
important to season the mixture as we go
along otherwise the nokia becomes really
bland
flour over the ricotta sieve so there's
no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
now
make a little well in the center
you want a nice soft
pliable ball of dough give that a really
good mix
get some thyme flowers in there
and this time is light fragrant and it's
just a really nice herb and with the
ricotta
it tastes brilliant just pick the little
tips the time flowers
next flour your hands generously and
knead the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is get it nice and smooth
as it starts to get a little bit wet and
just add a little touch of flour we want
something really nice and soft now don't
overwork it
it stops the nokia from expanding when
it hits the pan
that's exactly what i want a nice sort
of soft
fragrant ball cut the ball in half
lightly flour
the hands and just roll it
gently
just think of a big long cigar
the mixture will start getting a little
bit sort of wetter but do not add lots
of flour
now
lightly flour the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi it doesn't stick
cut the dough into bite-sized pieces
just take your finger dip it in the
flour and push down why i want my
knocking to look like a pillow
and for me the most important part there
is that not one of them are identically
the same shape
water on
bring up to the boil little touch of
olive oil in there lightly flour your
hand
lift up the nokia
in to the rolling boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom and let them simmer and
they start to sort of tell you they're
cooked when they start floating get a
pan on
get that nice and hot now they're just
starting to come up to the top and you
can continue cooking them like that i
like blanching them in the water taking
them out and then frying them to study
the gnocchi heat olive oil in a frying
pan
gently lift up and look
they've doubled in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside
nokia loves fresh pepper
so
pepper in
and you see as i start turning them got
this really nice little sort of
brown
color
and they're almost popping up now like
little parcels so i want them nice and
sauteed both sides but light
and creamy
in the center
fresh garden peas
in
and the butter gives it a really nice
sort of
bernoulli flavour on the end
beautiful
put a little bit of fresh thyme over the
peas and then finally i want to lift it
up fresh lemon
zest the lemon over
[Music]
so
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated piles and cheese give
your veg some attitude and you'll get
amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
cheap to make easy to cook and
absolutely stunning for me food always
has to be impressive but when it comes
to desserts
often you see spun sugar or wild
decorations remember simple
is always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
now cream cheese leave it out the fridge
for five or ten minutes go nice and soft
trust me your arms will be thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is new york
cheesecake because it's baked it says no
base start creaming the cheese and the
sugar
spending the amount of time i do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake rich delicious but
so simple
work the bowl
lift the bowl to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
nice and creamy
now
get your eggs
add the eggs to the mixture bit by bit
doing it this way it's more efficient
hey you're incorporating a lot of air
b the mixture doesn't separate
[Music]
the last of your
egg lovely
of course you can use electric mixer but
why go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
a cheesecake a day
keep the bingo wings away
now a couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk
stop something going lumpy
now i want to scent that cheesecake
i've got the freshness zest the lemon in
there i want to sort of tart it up even
more fold in some fresh raspberries
so just mix them through
be careful to crush them
then grease a cake tin with butter this
will ensure your cheesecake slides out
beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
the mixture hits the bottom of the cake
tin the raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries the top the middle and the
bottom it also stops all those little
pockets of air trapping underneath the
mixture in the cake tin there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
slightly souffled up
pull off
that's the color i wanted
on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest
yet the most stylish cheesecakes
anywhere
beautiful
[Music]
you